[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to our mac
site sponsored event titled a cgmp
compatible non-viral car t cell
manufacturing process
my name is leslie eschenger and i am a
director of marketing at backsight
i will be your moderator for today's
engaging session our speaker for today's
session will be andrew mancini field
application scientist at mac site
specializing in cell and gene therapy
andrew supported dr marston dr ian steen
and dr shy at ucsf with technical
assistance and troubleshooting
techniques to optimize their cgmp
workflow so he is very familiar with the
completed work and novel approach at
this laboratory i would like to remind
everyone that this session is meant to
be interactive so we encourage you to
participate by submitting questions at
any time during the presentation
let's get started
hi everybody thanks for joining my name
is andrew mancini i'm a field
application scientist at max site today
i'll be talking to you about work done
at the university of california san
francisco
focused on creating a cgmp compatible
non-viral car t-cell manufacturing
process using the maxi platform
i first want to begin with giving you a
brief introduction to car t-cell
engineering i know that most of you
present don't need any introduction in
this field however to make sure
everybody's on the same page i'll just
briefly go through what car t cells are
how they are made and where current t
cell manufacturing is going in the
future i'll then pivot that right into
the work that i want to discuss with you
today which is how the groups of
jonathan essentially
alex marsden and brian shy at ucsf
developed a hybrid ssdna template that
enables highly efficient non-viral car t
cell engineering
i'll first focus on a lot of the
developmental data which went into
creating these templates and validating
that they're effective
for car t cell engineering
and then i will lead that directly into
the relevant work in which they use this
process
to put together
a full non-viral cgmp compatible
clinical manufacturing workflow
using maxlite's gtx instrument in
conjunction with these hybrid ssdna
templates
we'll leave time for about 15 or 20
minutes of questions at the end of the
session
but of course at any time feel free to
put your questions in the chat be happy
to answer them as they come through
so i want to begin with talking a little
bit about about what car t cells are and
how they are made
so i'm sure that most of you here know
this but of course car t cell therapy
is based around taking a patient's own
immune cells
and then engineering them in a way so
that they can be used as an anti-cancer
therapeutic
the basic way that this works is that
you will have a patient with cancer
and you will collect the patient's
t-cells
via a process called leukopheresis
once you've isolated their t cells
you will then go to a series of steps to
manufacture the carb t cell products and
so car stands for chimeric antigen
receptor
and what this
does is that what we're we're taking
the patient t cells
we are enriching them and activating
activating them so that they begin
expanding
and then we are putting in
this chimeric antigen receptor into the
cells so that it is stably expressed by
the cells
and this car construct
enables the recognition of a specific
tumor antigen on the surface of the
cancer cells
which will then
allow the t cell to specifically target
and ideally begin killing the cancer
now once you have
introduced this car construct into the
patient t cells
historically done using lentivirus
you can then expand these car t cells
to hundreds of millions and billions of
cells
and then isolate the final product
purify it
and dose it back into the patient
and again these t cells have now a
receptor which is specific
to something on the tumor so something
like cd19 or bcma which is typically
targeted for in uh foreign consumers
and
now these t cells can be highly
effective in treating and even curing
the cancer that the patient has
now
as i said historically
car t cells have been made using
lentiviral
using lentiviral integration of the car
construct
so lentivirus has been used to introduce
introduce the
car construct into t cells
because lentivirus will integrate into
the t cells and you will have stable
expression
of this car
of this car molecule
no matter how many times the t-cells
expanded
both during the x-vivo manufacturing
process but also once it's dosed into
patients
of course that means that you will
always have a highly effective drug
product and you don't need to worry that
much about
the car receptor no longer being
expressed on your t cells
so while that all sounds great there are
a lot of challenges
involved with using viral vectors to
manufacture part t cells
and a lot of that is due to the
complexity
and costliness
of manufacturing viral vectors
at
a scale and under the regulations needed
so that they can be used to create car t
cells
um that are going into patients
so on this slide i put up
kind of a simplification of the entire
process not just the car t cell bio
which you saw on the previous slide but
also the viral vector bioprocessing
which needs to happen to generate the
car vectors which are used for stable
integration
you can see this is a
quite complicated process and there's a
very complex supply chain
and
um overall
um amount of work that goes into this
dramatically increases
the overall cost
and time for manufacturing rt cells
and so
in the previous years
there's been a significant focus at
looking for alternative methods
for manufacturing part t cells that
either don't rely as much on
the viral vectors
or completely gets rid of the viral
components
and we call these methods non-viral car
t-cell engineering that's what i want to
focus
on
for this talk today
and so
what if you could just completely remove
this entire block in red here
and instead of going through this entire
viral vector bioprocessing
you can replace it with a construct
which could be introduced into cells via
transfection um instead of through virus
and overall simplify
your car t-cell manufacturing
and so many groups have begun to go this
route
and develop a variety of car t-cell
engineering approaches that are either
partially or fully non-viral
these involve transpose mediated car
integration using transposes such as
piggyback or sleeping beauty in order to
have a stable semi-random integration of
the car construct into t-cells
there's also non-integrating methods
such as persistent car dna vectors
um such as epi vectors or
on smart vectors
which
do not actually integrate into the
genome but will stick around as episodes
and allow for stable car expression even
through many cell divisions
you also have more transient approaches
such as car mrna expression
where you take the car mrna
you
uh transfect it into your t cells x vivo
and then
in the time frame through which the car
is expressing sometimes 72 to 96 hours
you then dose the patient with those car
cells
now
where a lot of focus has been more
recently is developing nuclease-mediated
car knock-in methods and when i say
nuclease media i'm talking about using
something like a zinc finger nucleus a
talon
or more commonly crispr cast 9
in order to introduce
a donor template containing your car
in order to
specifically integrate
your car construct in a site direct
manner
and sometimes you are delivering this
donor carrying your car with aav
that is what is more of a hybrid
non-viral and viral approach
but more and more often you have groups
using synthetic dna templates
either small oligonucleotides or a
longer single stranded or double
stranded dna
in order to
introduce the car constructs stably
without relying on virus at all
and when we compare any of these
approaches to the viral approaches
what you see is that
overall
for
transpose needed integration
you know even the non-integrating
approaches but especially for the
nucleus mediated karnakans
there's plenty of advantages
that we
that these approaches have compared to
the viral approaches
such as high expression
you know stable integration
the
um
reduced immunogenicity
and a lower risk of random integration
compared to virus as well as simplifying
the manufacturing process
removing the whole viral supply chain
issues
and typically reduced costs
however compared to virus
typically these non-viral methods will
have
historically lower
transfection efficiency and lower carb
positivity
compared to the viral methods so while
you might end up with 60 to 80 percent
carb positivity
using a lentiviral approach
many times non-viral approaches will
struggle to get over 60
carb positivity in your final products
and so while this is specifically
transposon you can really apply both
these benefits and negatives
to any of the non-viral methods
which has groups searching for ways
to improve non-viral tar-t engineering
in a way that's able to match the
efficiency of viral approaches
and
one way groups are doing this
is leveraging
novel crispr mediated knock-in
techniques
for non-viral carti engineering that's
what the work i'll be talking about
today focuses on now before jumping into
that i just want to give everybody a
quick refresher as to what a crispr
mediated it is
so
for sure most of you know when you
deliver
crisper machinery
to a cell
you're usually taking either the cas9
mrna or or protein and casinos and
nuclease
and complexing it with a guide rna
which is directing it to a specific
genomic locus
you put these into your cell
using a transfection method typically
electroporation
um either using the maxi electroporation
platform
or one of the various other platforms
that are available
and once the casino nuclease and the
guide rna
is in the cell
you will have
the casting enzyme introduce a
double-stranded break
in the genomic dna
at the site specified by the guide irony
once this double-stranded break is
introduced in your target of interest
such as the track locus so it's the
t-cell receptor locus
you will have the repair of the
double-shared break occur through one of
two methods
this could be either non-homologous
end-joining ngj shown on the left in
this figure
where you have a
slightly random repair of the
double-stranded break
leading to small insertions or deletions
that occur during the nhgj process
this is typically used for gene
disruption say if you want to knock out
a specific locus
but if you want to knock in a piece of
exogenous dna into the genome
you instead try to focus on the homology
directed repair pathway or hdr
where you are supplying a donor template
that has some amount of homology
to your target of interest
as well as a
piece of dna that you're looking to
integrate
at your cut site
this can be a small piece of dna you
know only five to ten base pairs or it
can be a larger construct
that's multi-kilo bases such as a car
construct
when you deliver the crisper machinery
alongside this donor template
to your cells of interest
you will have the cells begin to undergo
homologous recombination
which will actually integrate
your
your donor dna directly into the genome
in a stable fashion
now when we look at how this is
happening you can see we have the cas9
complex
binding the target strand specified by
the guide rna that you used
and we have our hdr template with two
regions of homology and our desired
insert
when these are paired together we have
the homology donor template being used
to repair
that double stranded break thereby
giving us our insertion
and so
what
we'll be focusing on today
is methods as to which you can make this
hdr process more efficient
because in general hdr
even when you stack the deck and use
very good templates and very good um
crispr machinery
you will typically only have you know
eight to ten percent
of cells in your population
integrating your target in their genome
especially when it's a longer stretch of
dna like a carboxylic structure
now many groups have been working on
ways to
increase this efficiency as i mentioned
in order to get it closer to
viral integration
and one of these groups is the group of
alex marson at university of california
san francisco
in 2020
the margin lab released the paper
showing
the
use of modified repair templates that
allowed increased hdr efficiency
for the knock-in of car constructs
in primary t-cells
what they did is that they used
a
standard cas9 biorna system
but delivered these modified dnas which
were double-stranded
linear dnas
which had a dna insert surrounded by
homology arms similar to what you would
see for any standard
hdr donor template
but instead
of just leaving it there
on either end
of the construct you had truncated cas9
target sequences
or tcts sequences
which enabled the binding of cast 9
to the
donor template
but in a way where the cast nine was not
actually cutting the template
and so what this allows for
is that when you have the cas9
complex to the dna in the cell and the
cas9 has
a nuclear localization signal or nls
you will then get
highly efficient uptake
of your dna template
into the nucleus of the cell
where the hdr is going to occur
and so now you're stacking the deck
further
towards hdr by not only having
the template in the cell but making sure
it's getting to the nucleus alongside
cas9
and what this group showed is that this
was a very efficient strategy
to increase hdr efficiency and crispr
knock-in efficiency overall
four large constructs
in cells like primary t cells
so instead of having eight to ten
percent
car naked
you could use this strategy to go above
20 30 even 40 knock it
getting a lot closer to what you're able
to achieve
using
viral integration strategies
however
there's one thing about t cells that you
should know is that they don't really
like to have double stranded dna in them
and while this was an effective method
to increase the car knock-in efficiency
it had the downside of being
quite toxic
to the t cells they were trying to edit
and at especially higher concentrations
of
the
tcps donor template you saw quite a bit
of toxicity
due to the presence of this exogenous
dna in the t cells
and overall this limits the
efficacy of this approach
because you are essentially at a hard
cap for the amount of dna that you can
deliver
for the homology directed repair
else you have too much toxicity in your
population
and you are killing off any cell which
might even be undergoing
the crispr mediated naked
so
of course
the work and innovation didn't stop with
these double stranded templates
the marsden group alongside with
jonathan essence's group and brian shy
went back and
tried to find ways to continue to
optimize this approach
in order to enable
even more highly efficient non-viral car
t-cell engineering
and this is where these new hybrid ssdna
templates
come into play
and so the work that i'll be
showing you in the coming slides
is from this pre-print which is
available on bioarchive
titled hybrid single shared dna repair
templates enable high-yield genome
engineering in primary cells for disease
modeling and cell therapy manufacturing
again this is from the groups of
alexander marsden brian shine and
jonathan essence along with all of the
collaborators and co-authors also shown
up on this slide
and the overall goal was to find ways to
improve upon that initial double
stranded dna
of sequence with truncated task cas9
targeting sites
and in order to allow for even higher
efficiency genome engineering without
the toxicity in primary immune cells
and so
what the group did
is design a second generation of these
repair templates
using single stranded dna instead of
double stranded dna
for the homology directed repair
and
the reason why single stranded dna was
used here is in general while t cells
and other immune cells don't like double
stranded dna
they will tolerate single strand of dna
up to quite high
concentrations
meaning you could potentially load in
more of your template using single
stranded dna
compared to using a double stranded dna
donor
and
consequently potentially could have
higher rates
of car knocking using the strategy
and so
what this group did is they took the
double stranded templates with the cts
sites on either end and adapted them to
a single stranded model where the center
including the insert and both homology
arms was single stranded dna
and then because cas9
needs to bind double stranded dna
they have double stranded regions on
either side
which has the truncated cas9 targeting
sequences
and so on the left here shows the
variety of strategies which they
tested out in order to see which would
be
most efficient so these are labeled a
through j this corresponds to the x-axis
on the plot on the right
with different amounts of the
donor being given into the cells via
electroporation so 116 nanomolar 800
nanomolar or four micromolar from left
to right
and on the y-axis
the knock-in efficiency
um the knock-in efficiency at their
locus of choice
and
if we look at these different plots you
can see
um pretty readily that on the right hand
side so h i and j
ones where we have the single stranded
center with the double-stranded edges
were the most efficient across a variety
of concentrations
and with this approach
they were able to consistently get
up to 30
even close to 40 percent knock in
um at the higher concentrations
and we see though at the lower
concentrations
that this approach is quite effective
especially when compared to
the
single stranded control
so the
addition of the cas9 targeting sequences
on either side of the ssodn
significantly increased
the efficiency
of nockin which they were seeing
in their primary t cells
and overall after trying out all these
different approaches they settled on
using this construct j
which is
um i think what we consider probably the
most simplified of all the approaches
where we have the single stranded core
compared containing the insert with the
two homology arms
and then the cps sites are made double
stranded just by the annealing of a five
prime and three prime oligo
and so they then
while this was initially used for small
knock-ins as shown in this figure
they then want to apply this for
the knock-in of large constructs and
directly compare it to the
double-stranded approach
which was publicized in that 2020
manuscript
which i gave you a question to on the
earlier slides
and so this first strategy was to do a
1500 base paradockin of tngfr into the
ra locus
and this was done using the ss cts
templates as they are called
with this knock-in strategy they're able
to achieve up to 78 percent knock-in of
tnf tn gfr
and importantly not only was the
knock-in efficiency
higher
compared to the double-stranded approach
so at the double-stranded approach
you're capping out around 40 to 45
whereas with the single stranded
approach you're up to over 70
we can see that at these higher
concentrations
of the hdr template
we are maintaining significantly more
live cells
so we are able to avoid the toxicity
of the
double-stranded dna
cts template
while even improving further on the
knock-in efficiency
and overall you can see on the
right-hand graph here
that we are able to achieve
significantly more
car t
t cells with the knock-in
across the entire range of
concentrations compared to either
normal single-stranded dna in the light
grain
normal double-stranded dna in the dark
gray
or the cts double sharing the dna in the
blue
this was not exclusive to tngfr nockins
the il-2ra lucas
they also were able to efficiently knock
in several other constructs including
the bcma car shown here
this is an even larger insertion 2
920 base pairs and this is going into
the track locus so this is now actually
putting in a card construct
into a relevant locus
and with this strategy they're able to
achieve
39 percent knocking
of the bcma car
with again higher efficiency
compared to the double-stranded
um cts templates and the regular
single-stranded and double-stranded dna
and we're able to achieve again
significantly higher live cells
and car t cells
at the end of the process
so a median looks like
the use of these single stranded cts
templates pays off and
can
immediately circumvent
the main issue
with the double-stranded cts templates
and that is the toxicity
and so again this being able to get
around this toxicity means that you can
use higher amounts
of the hdr template for your process
thereby achieving higher knock-in
efficiencies
and even more importantly you can be
sure that your cells are healthier
throughout the process
so if you are making a cell therapy
you will have more active cells and more
happy active cells at the end of the
process
thereby likely leading to a more
efficient therapy
so this was you know quite exciting data
to see
because now you have a really robust
strategy
that can be used for crispr mediated
knocking in immune cells
and
not only was this able to be done at one
or two loci
they showed that
across 22 different genomic loci
you can achieve comparable if not
greater
knock-in efficiency compared to
alternative templates
and you know this demonstrates that
first of all that different loci have
different rates of knock-in as i'm sure
we all know based on genomic context
but that across the board
the
approach using the sscts templates
seems to be superior
um you know for
uh for about 19 of these 22 loci and for
the remaining three
it's comparable to the double-stranded
approach
so again showing the power of these ss
cts templates
and not only is this limited and this is
not only limited
to
bulk t cells but you can use this in a
variety of immune cell
immune cell
cell types
in order to achieve robust knock-in
um including individual cd4s and cp8s
that have been separated out
t-regs which are quite a sensitive cell
type responded particularly well
to the ss cts templates
as did hscs
b cells and k cells and gamma delta t
cells
all of these cell types
tend to react negatively when double
stranded dna is put into their
um into their cytoplasm
and so switching to the single strand of
dna repair templates
um allowed you to achieve significantly
higher not gain efficiency across the
variety of you know all the cell types
shown here and you can imagine that it's
not just immune cells which don't like
having dna put into them
for any cell type which is sensitive to
exogenous dna
i would imagine that the single stranded
cts approach
would allow you to achieve higher
efficiencies
compared to any alternative approach
using double stranded dna or
unmodified single-stranded dna
and so there's one additional i would
say very cool thing which came out of
this work
and that was
going beyond just modifying the
templates
and actually looking at other strategies
to which we can boost
the
hdr efficiency
for the knock-in of large
constructs into primary t cells
and
this approach was looking at small
molecule inhibitors
such as
agj inhibitors or
um
our hvac inhibitors which can be
combined with the cts templates
in order to further boost the knock-in
efficiency
and there's four drugs shown here tsa on
the left nu7441
the middle left m3814 in the middle
right and xl413 on the right here each
with different mechanisms of action but
all four of these drugs
at an ideal concentration shown in red
we're able to significantly boost the
knock-in efficiency
of the of the cts templates using crispr
in primary t cells
while having
minimal if any effect on the cell
viability
so now you can imagine this is another
tool in our toolbox
that we can use to begin making
non-viral crispr mediated karnakan even
more efficient
and so what
these groups did was
um then take these drugs either by
themselves
or in combination
and apply them to either the
double-stranded dna cts templates
or the new single-stranded dna cts
templates
and
um
ensure that
this these combos of small molecule
inhibitors did indeed increase the
knock-in efficiency
for
the template types and as you can see
here for both the cd5 aj knock-in and
the clta i'm cherry knock-in
the
single-stranded cts alone without drugs
already has a significant increase in
knock-in efficiency over the
double-stranded cts without drugs
but then as we begin adding in the small
molecule inhibitors either this mt
combination of tsa plus m3814 or the mtx
combination with all three drugs we can
improve this knockout this knock-in
efficiency even further
both
with the single stranded and
double-sharing the templates
so again this is another weapon in the
arsenal in order to really increase
the knock-in efficiency
and um it's the overall flexibility of
this non-viral approach
so everything i've shown you so far
has been done
at the small scale
um
using a
small scale research use electroporation
platform
in order to really develop these
templates and evaluate the feasibility
of this approach
however
you know university of california san
francisco has a big focus on
translational research and actually
getting the research
into a stage where it can be used to
develop treatments for patients
and the labs of alex marsden brian shy
and jonathan essensen in particular
are always focused
on
treating patients using the tools that
they develop
so the next step in this work
was to take
the single stranded templates which were
developed and which showed previously
can be used for karnakan
and integrate them into a gmp-compatible
non-viral car t-cell manufacturing
process
and this is where the maxsite platform
really came into
uh came into this work
because when you need to scale up
to transfect hundreds of millions or
billions of cells and you need to do it
in a way which is gentle
and also with an instrument which is
cgmp compatible
and has the backing of an fda master
file and is clinically validated
what many groups do is
use our maxsite gtx electroporation
platform
for their non-viral engineering
and so
what the mars
shy and essence then labs did was
use the max 8 gtx platform in order to
deliver
the crisper
genome editing machinery alongside the
sscts templates
as part of a car t manufacturing process
and this was using the bcma car
which i showed previously
in an autologous process
meaning that you have t cells isolated
from the patient
these were then activated and expanded
initially before some before the
electroporation
of a crispr rnp so the cas9 protein plus
the guide rna
alongside the sscts template for the
bcma card
these were then expanded for a further
eight days
until they would then be dosed back into
the patient for the treatment of
multiple myeloma
now
what they were able to achieve using a
gmp
this gmp compliant process
is in my opinion quite remarkable
because everything which was done in the
the process which i just showed you
was done in a way
which would be able to be translated
directly into a manufacturing space
again that's why we call it gmp
compliant
and rather
than seeing a drop-off
in the efficiencies
when
we did the scale up to a clinical scale
so transfecting now 100 million cells
instead of just like a couple million
cells
and doing this in a way where everything
is gp compliant
we were able to
not only
maintain the knock-in efficiency which
was done with a small scale we were
actually able to
significantly improve upon the knock-in
efficiency
so previously at the small scales
typically around
30 to 40 percent
for the bcma positivity
um
for the uh through the non-viral crispr
naked
now
in the setting where we are just using
the sscts template with no additional
small molecule inhibitors
at the clinical scale we were able to
achieve up to 46
knock in efficiency in primary t cells
at day 10
um end of the process
we were able to improve upon that
further
by adding in either m3814 by itself
or the mt combination so m3814 plus tsa
and this allows to achieve over 60
percent noggin efficiency
at day 10.
and this 60 barrier is what many many
groups have struggled to reach even at
the small scale
because this is
really comparable to a lentiviral
approach
and not only were we able to achieve
over 60
we did this in a process which could be
used to actually manufacture car t cells
for clinical use
and importantly when we look at
these cells
throughout the process and at the end of
the process we see three key things
first
we're able to achieve
the estimated patient dose that is
needed
and so on the left here we're looking at
the car positive cell count
so these are cells that are stably
expressing the bcma card
either at day 7
or day 10 of the process
and in the black gray line at the top
this is just the standard knock-in with
no inhibitors and you can see
we are able to achieve up to
about 1.5 billion car t cells at end of
process
now when we
add in
the small molecule inhibitors to
increase knock-in efficiency
we do see
a reduced expansion of the car positive
cells however even with the double small
molecule inhibitor combo
we are still exceeding the estimated
patient dose at the end of the process
so we have
multiple strategies
to achieve
the amount of car t cells that we
actually need to treat patients
and when we do immuno phenotyping of
these car t cells
we see that in all three conditions
these are enriched for the tscm
subpopulation subpopulations that's the
stem cell memory t cell phenotype
and that predicts highly effective t
cell therapy in vivo
and to cap this off when we do the in
vitro killing assay
you know no matter whether this was done
with no inhibitors with a single small
molecule inhibitor or the double combo
all three strategies
were able to robustly kill
bcma positive target cells
and so overall from this process
not only were we able to achieve a very
good car knocking
we are able to maintain good cell
expansion
achieve favorable t cell phenotypes
and ensure that the cells are functional
when aiming to kill their target tumor
cells
and so i will end it there
and leave you with a few conclusions
first i hope that this showed you that
the use of single-stranded dna hybrid
repair templates also known as sscts
templates is able to significantly
improve the efficiency of crispr
mediated karnakan
not only in primary t cells but also in
any cell type which is sensitive to
double stranded dna
additionally i hope that
you took away from this that this sscts
approach
is quite flexible it can be used
agnostically and in combination with
small molecules
for robust knock-in across cell types
and genomic loci
so wherever and whenever you need to do
a crispr knock-in
you can use
the ss cts templates
with any of the small molecules shown
here in order to really fine-tune your
process
and of course because we're always
looking towards treating patients
importantly
using the maxi gtx electro-creation
platform
we were able to scale up
this non-viral car t cell process
to a clinical scale in a gmp compliant
manner
in order to create a robust
car t cell manufacturing workflow
using the ss cts approach
and of course this is in my opinion the
most important thing because now
not only have you done the crucial
concept of small scale but this is
actively creating material which will go
into patients
so this is a great proof of concept for
combining a novel crisper knocking
approach and using the clinically
validated maxi gtx platform
in order to create a fully non-viral
electropre a non-viral car t cell
manufacturing workflow
so i will end it there and now i will
stick around to answer any questions the
next 15 or 20 minutes that you might
have i hope you hope you enjoyed and
will be more important to hearing all of
your questions
thank you
all right great uh unfortunately andrew
was unable to be live with us today to
support with the q a and in his absence
jordan design will feel a field
application scientist who works very
closely with andrew and is familiar with
the body of work will be joining us
today to answer some of your questions
so i want to let you know if we can't
address your technical questions during
this session
we will ensure someone from macsite or
ucsf will follow up to assist with the
answer
so i see quite a few questions have come
in i'm gonna go ahead and get started by
asking those uh jordan are you on one
yes i'm here thanks leslie for the
introduction
no problem all right number uh the first
question what was the cell viability or
live cell count for the control cells
that didn't receive the single stranded
cts
yeah that's a great question so if you
guys
take a second to look at the preprint
it's actually in the supplemental figure
number one um the live cell count for a
non-hdr
template control was about 25 million
cells
and every single
format a through h
of those short hair pins or single
stranded combinations were all up
between about 22 million to 30 million
so
roughly it was actually right in the in
the middle range of all the different
cell types so there wasn't really a
decrease in cell viability using the
single stranded templates versus the
non-treated control
great all right i see another question
here has come in does the single
stranded dna also facilitate larger
payload napkin
uh so they did try the biggest payload
they tried was the 2.9 kb payload the
bcma car knock in
um if you wanted to try something larger
they do see that there's a decrease
in efficiency quite rapidly once they go
past 80 micromolar of the
single-stranded cts dna template
so
you could try to
accommodate something larger but you'll
have to go down in the concentration
ratio of the template but
the martin lab has not tried something
larger than that 2.9 insert yet
um and can you explain the difference in
the effect of the cts addition
and or the double-stranded dna
substitution with the single strand of
dna for the 22 different genomic loci
from no effect to a substantial
improvement
yes it's too two critical components
right if you're comparing the
single stranded dna alone with the
single stranded gts uh insert that that
those cast nine target sites really bind
the cast cas9 and then facilitate that
entry into the nucleus so
that's really the main difference
between the single stranded alone and
the single stranded
with the cts template now when we're
talking about double stranded dna right
the difference is mostly due to that
reduced toxicity that you see
when you're when you have a single
stranded element composed to a
double-stranded
double-stranded dna so there's really
two different things um combining
together that are really increasing the
efficiency of that single stranded cts
template
next question are the small molecule
inhibitors approved for cell therapy
yes they are so everything that they
used in this exact study has been uh
currently in the clinic for other other
different types of drugs
going through phase trials
and how do these results compare to
other groups using a lentiviral approach
yeah so
this specific study wasn't directly
comparing a lentiviral approach however
we have a
seen groups try both the maxite
electroporation platform
uh in combination with a lentiviral
transaction so trying to compare the
direct2 in both cv8 positive t cells as
well as cd4 positive t cells and they
overall see at least an increase in 15
percent of
of
knock-in integration compared to the
lentiviral transduction so overall we do
see an increased deficiency using an
electroporation approach
great
uh next is what is the ratio of the tcts
primers to the hdrd
when preparing the mixture
is it a one to one and is there an
incubation period to prepare the single
stranded dna hdrt mix with the primers
yeah so it is a one-to-one ratio
so you're correct and then i think
there's they did an incubation of 30
minutes at room temperature to really
capture that
all right next question um
did any did the group do anything on off
target rates and were there any safety
concerns with the method
yeah so
i might have to defer to andrew getting
back to you on the specific off target
effect
there aren't too many safety concerns
with this method um we do see overall
that
uh
a
non-viral approach is much better than a
lentiviral approach when we talk about
the
the
end material coming out
and how we're going to translate that to
the patient so overall there's not too
many safety concerns that we have to
worry about
next question are the chemical
inhibitors that were presented
continuously
washed away at a certain time
um oh
do you mean were they presented
continuously or washed away yeah so they
were actually in
sorry they were actually introduced uh
immediately post electroporation um and
then they they did have it continuing
for about uh
24 to 48 hours post electroporation so
it was removed
great
and what is the cell viability after
transfection and how does
electroporation affect style viability
is there any decreased uh cell viability
percentage
yeah so this exact i kind of uh
mentioned that a little bit before but
this exact um these constructs and this
approach they actually didn't see a
decrease in cell viability too much post
electroporation um when we're
considering
uh
the
non-loading control so basically you're
electroporating but you don't have that
single stranded template compared to all
the the other single-sided templates
those all appeared around 25
million cells
post-electroporation
um these all these samples were
electrocuted at 100 million cells per
election so that was the starting um
cell count before we actually ran the
electroporation event
great
um another question came in is the max
site available for use in research as
well as commercially
yes that's a great question so we do
have it available for research we have a
lot of groups that purchase it for
research up to their pd
and then
when they want to transition to the
clinic they go to more of a licensing
agreement but we definitely offer
options
for both academics
and
research scale industry partners
to be able to use the system for
purchase
great and then what cuvettes are
processing assemblies um and or scale
did the group use and did they compare
small scale to larger scale
yeah that's a good question as well so
for for maxcite for the gmp component of
this they use the r1000 cuvette so
that's a one it goes up to a one mil
reaction um they actually did
electroporation for of the volume of 600
microliters in that r-1000 cuvette
and they
electrocuted like i said 100 million
cells per electroporation event
and uh they did do they did do smaller
scale experiments um they used a
different electroporation system other
than the max size for the smaller scale
work actually um but it wasn't directly
translatable and scalable to the gnp
environment so that's why they moved to
the maxlite gtx system
and you might not be able to answer this
one jordan but i i will ask it uh
is there a cost comparison that was done
between the viral approach and the
non-viral approach that you could speak
of or is that in the in the actual
publication
uh that you that marcin and his group
completed
yeah so they do not do a direct
comparison between the two methods uh in
the system um i do know that we have a
bunch of customers who have done that
cost analysis before and also members of
our own sales team that have um so we
can definitely follow up with you with
more information on that
great
and is there any uh concerns with
availability of and compatibility with
gmp quality materials
yeah so uh when we're thinking about gmp
compatible material availability it's
been a little different right now with
covid um and we've seen that some some
some companies out there are struggling
to find materials
without coping consideration you should
be able to get these gmp compatible
compatible reagents however right now we
are seeing some longer lead times
to get those materials so if you are
interested in doing a study like this i
suggest
planning ahead of time definitely
because we've got the cover delays going
on right now
all right and i'm seeing a couple more
come in this is another one about off
target reits and we'll get back to you
on that another one about safety
concerns and we already mentioned and
addressed that
um and then well maybe this will be the
last one that we ask although again i
don't know if you'll be able to ask
answer this one jordan but we'll try it
out
has the marsa lab compared the immune
phenotypes with the resultant car t
cells and those products and has the use
of the double-stranded dna knock-in
templates varied um compared to the
viral rectors
so they have done
um
oh directly so you want to know the
comparison between double dna nausea and
viral vectors they have not done that
direct comparison
sorry i met with the phenotypes have you
looked at the phenotypes of the
resultant car t cells with the products
from the double-stranded knock-in
templates or viral vectors and i think
the answer is still no but
um
yes so they have compared the immune
phenotypes of their single stranded dna
knock-in with their double-stranded dna
knock-in
and those are very similar or the same
but they have not with viral vectors
perfect okay i think that wraps up and
that's pretty much uh most of the
questions i think that we've had quite a
few duplications but i think that
addresses everything
i want to remind our audience that the
recorded version of today's talk will be
made available soon after this live
session and you will be notified when it
becomes available and before i go i want
to take time to thank andrew for all of
his efforts and proprieting our viewers
with this detailed presentation
uh to jordan for filling in last minute
with uh the great answers to the great
questions that our audience has had
today
to lab roots for hosting the events and
also to our audience participants for
joining us today and for their
intriguing question
this concludes our session for today and
until next time have a great day
you